her passion is farming fish Rick ELISA
Reineke is 16 and still at school four
years ago she started implementing an
aquaponic system on her father's farm in
Pretoria South Africa it combines
conventional aquaculture like raising
fish in tanks with hydroponics
cultivating plants in water she started
out with a thousand fish now her
experiment has grown into a business
that supplies fish and greens at the
same time so you can put it in your
backyard
the system can feed about four to six
people on a regular basis you can make
the person and some sustainable with
fish and vegetables so it has a high
protein and a good value of food
alternative systems like this one are
especially important as South Africa
suffers from one of the most severe
droughts in its history many farmers
have lost crops and animals due to the
lack of water we're getting nowhere near
the rainfall which should beginning at
this time of the year the sort of season
and it's having a devastating effect on
the on the water table all holes are
drying up one of the things we're going
to be doing this week is actually
lowering up warhol trying to get a
little bit more water out of it we have
two boreholes that have literally dried
up now that we can't even use aquaponics
is a reliable alternative especially in
dry times Rick ELISA uses what she calls
a decoupled system in order to save
water it's a simple way to recycle used
water back into the system we send all
that water to an apron tank a 10,000
tank
from there it's been filtered through
this system the plants absorb all the
nutrients and then after an eight-hour
cycle the water is cleaner than what it
was in the first and so same thing we
sent this water back to the fish dams so
this is basically a big big filter or in
natural ways you can say it's a big
wetland
another advantage you can grow anything
from cucumbers to tomatoes and lettuce
Ric Elise's vision is to roll it out to
places where people are poor and water
is scarce and you can sell sunny to have
an income as well in South Africa
aquaponics is still in its infancy so
far there are more than 190 freshwater
and over 30 saltwater aquaculture farms
officials see a lot of growth potential
in aquaponic systems we have aquaculture
arenas campaigns we also have programs
whereby during our news campaigns we
actually go and hold the holder farmers
hand by hand to advise them on how to
start an aquifer in aquaponics farm we
give them step-by-step advice I do not
think think that the government has
helped us enough especially for young
upcoming entrepreneurs who needs funding
who needs financial advice I don't think
I've got enough help and advice from the
government in South Africa with or
without government support Ric ELISA
Reineke will continue her business and
passion growing vegetables and farming
fish on a big scale